I'm Keith Winston I'm here in computer
science and my almost entire group
showed up to this this is the first time
I've seen them all together so they will
be answering all the questions at the
end so I'm very happy to have questions
or interruptions in the middle please
just go for it I'm here to tell you
about sort of a style of building
systems that we've used in our group
that has a number of applications
there's no sort of functional
programming but not in the you know
Haskell kind of sense but just in the
idea that it can be helpful to take a
sort of mega system and divide it up
into sort of small granular pieces so
the message of this talk is that sort of
granular functional interfaces to
computing resources reasoning carefully
about state is going to open up new ways
of doing things or new ways of doing
existing things and new things that we
can do and I think based on our
experience so far we think there's a
pretty strong case that it's worth
refactoring sort of the mega modules
that we have today things that people
are scared of touching things like TCP
congestion control or video codecs or
compilers or machine learning kernels
these are things that people should have
reluctant to do by themselves or
reluctant to redo you know oh that's you
need an expert to do video codec or you
know you need an expert to do congestion
control you know I don't think that's
true I mean I do these things I'm just
sort of a dilettante you don't you don't
need to be an expert and you especially
don't if you can reason carefully about
state and if the consequences of a
mistake are not that bad because there's
sort of no side effects so this ability
to sort of save and restore the state of
a mega module saving restore the
programme state it's a powerful tool
because you can always sort of back up
so I'm going to tell you about four
systems that we built that sort of
demonstrate this idea so the first is a
system for fast interactive video
encoding called X camera the second is
work we did with Dropbox to recompress
all of the JPEGs hundreds of petabytes
of JPEGs that are in the Dropbox
distributed file system the third is a
real-time video conferencing system that
has again one of these purely functional
systems and the fourth affair time to
get to it is a system for outsourcing
anything to the cloud sort of make - a
1,000 1,000 way parallelism and each of
these uses this functional idea for a
different benefit so in the X camera we
have a purely functional video codec
that we use to get fine-grained massive
parallelism to reducer to the end and
completion time in the case of the JPEG
recompression we have a functional JPEG
codec a functional Huffman encoder
Dease predicted huffman encoder that we
use to be able to shard the JPEG files
that Dropbox has on a distributed file
system so we can break them up into tiny
little pieces that's compatible with
their sort of the redundancy story there
they're sharding story in the case of
the video conferencing the real-time
video we use this functional abstraction
to be able to explore an execution path
without committing to it say you know
what if we encoded the video to high
quality what if we included the video to
low quality and then we'll make a
decision which one we wanted to do only
after the fact we considered rewind
State and in the case of the the GG the
massive compilation we have this
abstraction we call a cloud thunk that
allows us to have sort of any task to
the cloud to these cloud functions for
pennies so you can take a normal sort of
unix pipeline like a makefile
and infer one of these functional you
know a lambda expression really from it
and then run that with massive
parallelism across thousands of workers
or locally and you know sort of get the
same answer so there's four different
benefits from this quasi functional
functional ish style all right so let's
go into the first one which is the
fine-grained parallel video processing
so this was a 10 STI last year
motivation here is that video is really
painful to do with who here has maybe
kids and you've edited a home movie
maybe a home movie not about your kids
yeah all right sir with it with kids
with that okay and how long was the
video okay and did you edit it or do
anything to it in the computer okay how
what what kind of change you make like a
cut or change the colors or picking
pieces and splicing them together all
right and then how long did that take
and end to re-render after you did that
months that seems crazy from you making
a change for someone else in the world
to be able to see that change yeah yeah
and even if it was so-called real-time
it would still have taken you like 18
minutes right the playback might have
taken three hours to do whatever had to
be done
Oh granted I don't know what it was
actually happy
there's no that's how long it took or
there was a new file I can look at yes
if you think about the things that have
made computing like really different
especially things around here like you
know the Xerox Alto right or like the
mother of all demos like the amazing
thing here was you could take something
and make it interactive and see the
results immediately or sketchpad any of
these systems the interactivity is a
powerful thing I remember Mike right I
mean Mike right was amazing it was like
the paragraphs would reflow as you typed
fantastic and now we have this insert of
Internet collaborative way we have
Google Docs or if I'm we're looking at
the same document and I mean X you know
not only do I see the X and the text
reflow on my screen but everybody else
sees it too at the same time the results
of making a change are instantly visible
it's just like sort of the old-fashioned
way where you'd like put a pan on a
piece of paper and it would like happen
immediately it's like revelatory to have
that in the computer context that's
Google Docs but we don't have this for
video video is the most popular kind of
content on the internet by time spent by
byte sent it's the vast majority of
content set over the internet but to
manipulate video is a huge pain in the
neck there's no way to have a sort of
instant editing and transformation in a
collaborative sense of a video it would
be very nice to have you can imagine
here you have some video what if you
wanted to experiment apply some filter
to video that would be nice or we could
do some analysis like you know instead
of skip to the next chapter of the DVD
what if we skip to the next time we see
this actor be nicer how many times this
actor appear you know along you know can
we see a scene that has this actor in
this actor together can we edit that
together what if you wanted to take
actor and remove them from the movie
that could be nice to just like
automatically fine and replace like take
someone just take them out it would be
nice to play with these sorts of
transformations in a you know make right
type sense you know like a sketch pad
type steps like immediately not have to
wait months to rerender an 18 minute
video so if you think about what it
would take from a systems perspective to
accomplish this you know the question
would be a standard toolbox can we just
put a lot of computers on it can we have
massive parallelism to be able to apply
these video operations just very very
quickly
Bob iMovie course
[Music]
well I think it depends and we'll see
some numerical benchmarks alright I mean
you were at Apple probably with like a
high-speed line well we'll show the
benchmarks so the challenge if you
wanted to do this with massive
parallelism there's sort of two
challenges one is you would need to be
able to summon thousands of threads
thousands of course at once doing this
operation you're on Mik right you can
hit an X and it's sort of an eight
kilohertz megahertz now what was it it
was to kill to maker some early
Macintosh can reflow the text was that
some number Hertz Macintosh could reflow
the tank and that was considered a a
major accomplishment at that time that
you could have sort of real-time you
know text reflow
but to do this with video would take
just like many many you know thousands
of computers and you'd have to be able
to summon them only when the user was
doing an interactive operation it would
be way too expensive to have these
computers just sitting there
humming waiting for you to do something
that's part one you have to have the
available power ilysm the second thing
is that how do you get on your
calculation paralyzed enough to make use
of that kind of level resource so the
challenge with video compression is that
the finer grain of parallelism if you
try to divide up a video into thousands
of tiny pieces the compression
efficiency actually gets worse and worse
so there's sort of a fundamental reason
that limits the available parallelism in
this task so that's sort of what our
project was about was addressing those
two challenges so the first is that we
made a framework to run these sort of
five thousand way interactive parallel
jobs with inner thread communication on
a commercial cloud function service and
number two we developed a purely
functional video codec that allows us to
start encoding chunks for mid-stream it
allows us to have a granularity of
parallelism that is finer grained than
the dependency boundaries in the video
stream I'll talk about them in a second
so Hostos we call this X camera so part
one is this realization that we had that
these cloud functions services had an
unrealized power these are servers like
AWS land or Google cloud functions or as
your functions they were intended for
sort of event handlers and web micro
services sort of asynchronous tasks
where there's a million people with cell
phones and maybe occasionally one of
them will do something and then when
that happens one of these functions will
get fired off and reply and the cool
benefits is that you know your it's not
like you're booting up over
machine every time I mean I know VMware
was a very successful company but yeah
this is being videotaped anyway I love
VMware if you think about what should be
the abstraction to program the cloud the
idea that you have to have a simulation
of an x86 computer with a you know
pretending they have access to the x86
chip and a fake Ethernet card and a fake
hard drive and and and RAM you know your
own RAM and that you have to then boot
the operating system before you can do a
calculation it seems like there's other
abstractions we could think about for
how to program the cloud because in this
case if you you know to boot up an
Amazon virtual machine you know it takes
a minute or so to boot up they bill it
based on the minute you know there's a
minimum sort of minute to pay for it and
you'd have to wait like a minute before
you could actually do anything because
like Linux is booting up so the
beautiful thing with this new
abstraction this age of us lambda is you
don't have that that you can run
thousands of threads it turns out you
can run arbitrary Linux executables we
discover you just upload a static Linux
executable you can run it and they boot
up in less than a second and the billing
is less than a second so you can imagine
an application your computer that would
normally take one hour what if the
computer could tell you know what we can
do this locally it'll take an hour or I
can fire up 3600 lambdas like that each
one will run for one second we still get
an hour of CPU time that's gonna cost
you less than a dime I mean that's the
economics I think it's a pretty I would
pay the nine cents to save an hour of
CPU time to go from an hour to one
second I think you can imagine any
interactive application might be this
way sort of pervasive parallelism for
interactive applications so we built a
library to enable this a library that
fires off thousands and thousands of
lambdas running a arbitrary sort of
executable very very quickly so you know
we use a lot of sort of engineering
tricks like we open up a lot of TCP
connections and we fire them off at the
same time these are not maybe that
intellectually interesting but we built
this framework that that allows us to
harness the parallelism of lambda for
these sort of not asynchronously
parallel jobs but burst parallel jobs we
want to come in and say I want 5,000
lambdas right now and when we
communicated with this to Amazon we all
flew up there we had like a hard time
communicating with them because we said
you know you know they won't only wanted
to give us like a thousand concurrent
lambdas and we said you know can we have
many many more and they said well how
many requests per second does your
application have you know think of it
like an asynchronous thing we said well
most the time zero and then occasionally
when the user hits a
you know I want as many as it'll give me
I mean if we could have a million we'd
love a million so like so a million per
second like snow just a million every so
often that was sort they really don't
like that because you know they want to
have to provision for us but it's sort
of the difference between circuit
switching and packet switching if you
think about like booting up VMs for an
hour that's kind of like the AT&T you
know circa 1955 model the circuit
switching and what we're asking for is
this more packet switched as an analogy
packet switch interface to the cloud
where we can say I want 5,000 functions
now and 3,000 function now and they'll
be very short-lived and this was a
challenge when they were starting the
internet you know when the internet
people in Kleinrock called up 18t and
says i want to be able to send one
packet they said well sir there's a six
minute minimum time you know any
telephone call you can have a telephone
call send whatever you want over but
we're gonna bill you for six minutes no
matter what you do
that's kind of the world we're in now or
they're you know the VMS are gonna bill
us for a minute whatever we doing we
want a microsecond but to have this sort
of packet-switched interface to the
cloud it turns out to be very very
powerful so we were able to get these
threads we can have five thousand
threads starting at the same time but
the challenge is how do you use five
thousand threads at the same guy didn't
compress a video because the challenge
is the finer grain the parallelism the
worse the compression efficiency let's
talk about why that is what is a video
codec it is to modulars a video encoder
and a video decoder with a contract
between them that you can have raw
pictures coming in on the left raw
images off a camera going to the video
encoder and in the middle there's an
opaque bit stream and they'll go into
the decoder and then on the right side
you get some fuzzy version of the
pictures on the left that's the contract
for the end coder and the decoder
there's a stream in a stream of pictures
produces a stream of bits produces a
stream of reconstructed pictures and the
way that the compression can reduce the
number of bits from the sort of
representation of the right image is to
exploit the correlation between adjacent
frames so if I was taking a video of you
right now you know the first frame I
would have to send everything I see I'd
have to compress it only using
information within the first frame sort
of like I just a JPEG picture just a
snapshot but on the second frame what I
can tell that what the encoder can tell
the decoder is hey remember that frame I
just sent you it's gonna be very similar
so for this little square of the frame
it's gonna be exactly the same and for
this little square is almost the frame
would just move it up down one pixel
into the left a half pix
in the next frame it's almost the same
but I'm gonna add this residue to it and
that's how the video compression works
is by exploiting the correlation between
the adjacent frames and that it's called
motion compensated prediction turns out
to be extremely powerful so in a typical
4k or virtual reality stream the first
frame the one that stands by itself is
called a keyframe that consumes about a
megabyte in a typical video and the
second frame and the subsequent frames
is 40 times smaller it's like 25
kilobytes each so there's a considerable
experience see the correlation between
adjacent frames and it's the search for
those correlations finding the most
concise way to express the difference
between adjacent frames that consumes
most of the CPU of a video compression
engine just finding the what is the
correlation these slides are all online
you can I can they're all they're not a
secret so the interface that is a that
is advertised by commercial video
encoders and decoders whether they're
hardware software is this sort of stream
to stream interface there's an encode
function or a code module and the input
is a stream of pictures and the output
is one keyframe that's like a megabyte
and then a stream of inter frames that
make use of the previous frames and the
contract is you can put that same
sequence of frames one keyframe in a
bunch of inter frames in the decoder and
get back a stream of reconstructed
pictures that's the contract and this if
you you can go to Sony and buy a chip
that implements this you can get it in
software no matter how you get it this
is sort of the interface that you get
the challenge is that it makes it harder
to I mean if you're building a
high-definition television this is great
there's a TV station broadcasting a
stream of bits you show it on the screen
it's perfect if you're trying to do
something interesting that manipulates
the stator that paralyzes this is not
the right abstraction it makes things
very challenging because let's say we
have these 200 frames we want to encode
them we end up with one key frame and
199 inter frames
no problem serve one megabyte and then
each one of these is 40th of that what
happens we want to split it into sort of
20 different threads and do it in
parallel well thread one encodes ten
frames and it's with one key frame and
nine inter frames the same time thread 2
encodes of different 10 frames ends up
with one key frame and 9 their frames
etc each one of these threads ends up
contributing an extra megabyte to the
compressed result and so the more
find the finer grain the parallelism the
more keyframes they have to insert the
more sort of state refreshes or
dependency boundaries and a sort of
memory sense it's a guarantee that this
chunk can stand alone it's not going to
depend on anything else the more memory
dependency founder's we insert the worse
the compression efficiency so it's not
really economical from a compression
standpoint to have this finer finer
grained parallelism so systems like
YouTube for example they use a
granularity of 128 frames which is about
what is five seconds or so that's sort
of how often they refresh the stream
because more than that becomes more
expensive so in order to exploit the
parallelism that lambda and this mew
library make available to us we need a
way to start encoding for midstream
we need a way to tell the encoder you
know what you're encoding this tiny
chunk here but don't start with a
keyframe you need to start with
knowledge of the state of the decoder
that you can't just assume it's in some
initial state that you get to initialize
from scratch because that's just too
expensive so to do this we had to be
able to define what do we mean by the
state of the decoder we were on a Tele
encoder start encoding from mid stream
how do we define mid stream so we we
implemented a video codec for this
Google vp8 format and we did it in a
very rigorous way called explicit state
passing style which is a purely
functional style so we had to define
what does it mean the state of the
decoder so we defined the video decoder
as an otamatone as sort of a finite
state transducer so it starts out in
some initial state and it consumes a key
frame so this is a coded frame here this
line this is like bits on the coming
over the coming over the wire it
consumes a key frame and it traverses
and enters a new state this is the new
state of the decoder then it consumes an
inter frame it traverses and enters a
new state consumes inter frame traverses
and enters a new state and every time it
takes one of these state transitions it
spits out an image for display on the
screen this is a formal definition of
what the video decoder is doing and each
one of these inter frames is designed to
be applied to a particular source state
so there's an assumption in the inner
frame that these are the this is the
information that's available so that's
how we define the video decoder here's
actually the contents of the state it's
a sort of Bunch it's a it's a few images
that have been saved and some
probability tables for the arithmetic
code that's the source state and then
the target state is different imagers
saved and maybe different probability
tables and there's some
image that got sent off to the screen so
what we implemented was a purely
functional version of a vp8 video coder
and decoder so this is a
standards-compliant vp8 encoder and
decoder but they're implemented in this
way where there's no side effects and
it's purely functional and it's in C++ I
don't want to suggest there's no like
Haskell smart person stuff here it's
very just normal normal programming but
it's done in a way with no side effects
at purely functional so we have a decode
function and the inputs are the frame
it's supposed to be decoding those are
the compressed bits but also this
explicit object that represents the
state that it's in let's provide it
explicitly and the output is an image
for display to the screen but also the
new state for the next time that you're
gonna run the decoder so you could
decode any video on YouTube this way any
vp8 video on YouTube it'll work you just
have to keep applying this decode
function over and over again and save
this state object and every time you
apply the decoder put the new state
object in to the code function and then
it'll give you a new state object and
then you run that the next time you sort
of thread it through like that so that's
the purely functional decoder for vp8
and then we implemented the the
corresponding encoder which takes as
explicitly the same state object now
that's the same kind of state object
there's an image coming off the camera
but we tell the encoder this is the
state of the decoder that you can assume
that it's in and it produces a
compressed frame an intra frame that
relies on have the decoder having been
in that state this is a purely
functional no side effects
implementation of one step of a video
encoder and finally we implemented a
transform that modifies compressed
frames into a different version of the
same compressed frame we call this
rebase so it takes an inter frame that
was intended for one state and it
modifies it to be applicable to a
slightly different state still targeting
the same image of the camera so this is
kind of I can get in software
development if I have some state of my
software repository and I want to make a
whole bunch of changes I can hire a
bunch of people on up work and ask a
thousand different people to make a
thousand different changes in parallel
and they all make a change on the same
version of the repository and I end up
with a hundred get commits all dependent
on the same repository state so now what
do I need to do
well rebase was the answer I said before
yeah rebased was the was the the hope
for answer I need to rebase these on top
of each other produce a linear history I
need to sort of cherry-pick them in and
turn these commits that were intended
for one history one one state of the
repository to be applicable to a
different state a slightly different
state so that they could have a sort of
linear history so that's the the third
operation so we do that for these video
frames and that the hope here is that
the rebus operation will be pretty cheap
because once you already know what's in
the compress frame and you know the
temporal correlations you know that this
car and this frame is the same as this
car in this frame you already have that
information so you just have to sort of
recode these residues but it's a it's a
small change so the algorithm we have
here is to try and do as much as
possible in parallel and then do that
rebasing which is a sort of linear step
do that at the end in serial but that
supposed to be a cheap thing so we have
the parallel step where we encode the
tiny independent trunks and then a
serial step where we erase the extra key
frames and we thread it all together so
we end up with a playable video that
doesn't have a lot of key frames even
though it was encoded mostly in fine
grained parallelism so I'll show you
what that looks like
step one we have all these separate
threads we got five thousand threads
running on a Tobias lambda all at the
same time and each one downloads a few
frames let's say six frames of raw video
from the camera X camera and then it
encodes them the sort of simple way the
you know that using a production video
encoder from Google we encode them and
we end up with one keyframe and then
five inter frames in each chunk so now
we actually we have a playable video you
could play this you want you start here
you play this then you throw that state
away start here play this throw that
state away start here play this it'll
play it'll just be very big because
every one of those key frames is like an
extra megabyte so the question is can we
now rewrite those key frames and turn
them into intro frames so we're gonna do
that we're gonna have our encoder start
from mid stream so we figure out what is
the exiting state of every chunk here
the final state and we in parallel send
that to the next thread and then we have
the next thread encode the first image
in terms of that exiting state instead
of in terms of this sort of initial
blank state in terms of the exiting
state so it looks like that I'll go back
once this is what we had this is what we
end up with so we run our encode
function that was this the one time that
function is going to get invoked to an
code the first image in terms of the
exiting state of the previous chunk and
now what we have to do is just we don't
quite have a playable video now because
we play here where we ended up here now
we're stuck there's no way to get up to
here so we now have to do is just rebase
these states are very similar so just
gonna rebase this chunk to be applicable
to this state like that and we do it
again and we do it again that's a serial
step so most of the work is done in
parallel but that rebase happens at the
end so that's the algorithm and there's
a few different variations we can run
different numbers of frames in each
chunk and we can rebase and stitch
different numbers of chunks together and
I'll show you an evaluation here so this
is looking just at the compression
efficiency so the questions as the bit
rate goes up how good does the quality
go up so this is a standard metric
structural similarity and so we can see
the best encoder you can get this is
Google's VPX encoder with one thread no
parallelism as the bit rate goes up
definitely the quality goes up and
Google's multi-threaded encoder this is
what the maximum parallelism that they
have you know there's a compromise
because we end up not being able to
predict across these boundaries it's
still pretty good but that's this is the
best Google can do in a sort of
multi-threaded way
let's now let's look at the dumb hyper
parallel way where we just encode
separate six frame chunks but we don't
stitch them together so how it looks
like this is not that good and now the
question is what if we encode the
separate 6 6 train chunks but then we
stitch 16 of them together in a row so
we eliminate 15 key frames that looks
like this so we're able to get almost
the same compression efficiency as a
function of bitrate almost the same
qualities of function of bitrate as the
Google encoder using this much finer
grained parallelism just the quarter of
a second chunks so that's the
compression efficiency now let's talk
about how long it takes so that that
best best-of-breed encoder takes seven
and a half hours so we should say we
took a four to 15 minute video 4k video
uploaded it while we you know we tried
to encode in various ways so this 15
minute 4k video the best best ever
encoder takes seven and a half hours to
encode and that's on a fast Intel
machine and the super parallel encoder
from Google takes two and a half hours
we also looked at you know what if you
sort of had access to all the
parallelism you could imagine I mean
Google's got a ton of computers so let's
just upload the video to YouTube and let
them encode it and that takes 37 minutes
for their fastest encoder
but that's only using this parallelism
of every 128 frames so the question is
you know what if we use 20 times more
parallelism we'll going from 128 frames
we have six frame trunks and it ends up
about fourteen times faster so we're 20
X the parallelism about 14 X 2 speed
compared with sort of end n YouTube and
this is sort of to make the video end
and available on the web so the whole
pipeline so that's the sort of speed
comparison so you know the the lessons
here number one these these lambdas can
be used for a lot more than sort of
asynchronous
event handlers they can be used to these
burst parallel tasks and they sort like
a supercomputer that you can access you
know paying by the tenth of a second
it's very powerful abstraction and I
think it's going to allow us to paralyze
all kinds of jobs if we can express the
job in a fine-grained parallel way which
even with considerable overhead is gonna
have a huge benefit taking things that
take an hour and being able to do them
in one second it's just so powerful I
mean that's sort of the lesson of all
interactive computing so I don't think
it's gonna be just video editing and
home movies but you know any sort of
filter or 3d artists you know the people
at DreamWorks when they want to see you
know should I move the light on Shrek's
head from here to here it takes
something like four hours to see the
result of that they have a very parallel
operation they can probably render all
of the movie in four hours but that's
because they have a cpu for each frame
that doesn't help if you're trying to
make an artistic decision about where
should the light be on this particular
frame so being able to do that with
massive parallelism or any sort of
compilation which I'll talk about later
if we have time or or interactive
machine learning or data visualization
or any database query or Google search
or genomics all of these applications I
believe may have a button on your screen
it says okay I'll do this calculation
you press this button it could take an
hour or press this one button I'll do it
in one second it'll cost you nine cents
I think we're sort of you know back to
the 60s where computing is going to be a
sort of you know build by the
millisecond utility but will have access
just like so much powerful paddles in
the cloud if if we can treat application
stage as a first-class object if we can
divide up our tasks with sufficient
parallelism so that's sort of part one
I'm gonna move on if there's no
questions
yes sir was that from the key frame each
enter frame was gonna be smaller that
goes from what you
had produced two what you need to start
from which may not be as dense as the
inner frames your computing earlier
well that operation has access to the
original image so we really just throw
this keyframe away and we make a fresh
inner frame make that fresh inner frame
working from both ends both what you
started with after several steps of
compression and what you need to start
with is something it would be ideally
your keyframe for the next you're
throwing away a keyframe
but you need to exactly reproduce that
keyframe in order to have the starting
point that the next stage is all
expected well it's not exact it's the
sort of secret here is that when we
rebase is how we patch up those residue
differences so it's it's not exactly to
do it exactly would be very expensive
intermediate frames and have the same
compression ratio as the inner frames
that you would have with the
conventional technique you know it's a
hard question to answer that precisely
because that inner frame is encoded with
our encoder which he wrote and the
original inner frame was encoded with
Google's encoder so to answer that
question fairly would probably require
more more work yes sir go back to that
illustration so the way you have it
drawn here - and I could be completely
wrong it looks to me like it's a
synchronous serial string well okay so
this part is parallel it's well
alternately we end up with a playable
video so yeah it is a the decoder will
download this and just play it in order
what they so you're finding if thread
two needs an inter frame from thread one
to start thread thread - how does thread
to start before thread one completes
well so this so this part happens in
parallel and then this part happens in
parallel where they share they're
exiting state with the next thread and
then this part happens in parallel
all right what do we move on we can I
can show you we have another graph on
this that might help you at the end all
right so the second application of these
sorts of techniques was something we did
with Dropbox where they have a whole
bunch of JPEGs in Dropbox this is also
last year so Dropbox has roughly one
exabyte of other people's data in it and
all these things have been uploaded to
Dropbox and the median number of times
that they get downloaded anyone want to
guess zeroes is the answer most most
files uploaded are never downloaded most
YouTube videos are never watched most
people never tweet the Internet is
mostly just a ghost town so yes but they
nonetheless have an exabyte of people's
data which they have pledged to not lose
and about a third well more than a third
of it like 40% was JPEG files people's
people's pictures a lot of these were
taken with mobile cameras so you know if
you imagine that's roughly 300 petabytes
of JPEG files the company is very
incentivized to want to save back-end
space so you imagine how how would they
do that and you could think well you
know JPEG was standardized in 1989 and
when people use JPEG they only use
techniques that were not patented in
1989 so maybe there's something over the
last you know 30 years of compression 29
years a compression that have improved
that we can use to recompress these JPEG
files now the the simplest way to do it
would just be to decode the JPEG file
and then recompress it into some more
modern image format like htif or
whatever but you can't do that because
people would be pretty angry if you
change the contents of their files in
this distributed file sitting up someone
has their jpeg and a git repository and
you just go and change it and they say
well now my hashes don't match you say
oh no sir it's better that doesn't fly
in the file system business so you have
to keep the exact same constant of file
but nonetheless you know if you look at
how JPEG works there's a there's pixels
coming in and then there's a lossless
transform that's applied there's a
discrete cosine transform that's
basically lost list but then those
coefficients the DCT coefficients are
divided by a quantizer and that's the
lossy step it's an integer division so
they're divided and then rounded off to
the nearest integer
that's the lossy step and then at the
bottom of this pancake those
coefficients are just written out using
a Huffman code that's a totally lossless
operation so the theory would be let's
just strip off this the
the pancake decode those coefficients
we're not gonna change anything about
the lossy part but we'll just Rhian code
the same coefficients using a smarter
code maybe an arithmetic code something
like that so people have done this and
we can look at how well these techniques
work so here we're seeing the
compression savings as the compression
savings go up and here we'll see the
speed of the corresponding decompressor
so the best algorithms are sort of up
and to the right and you can look one
thing you can do is just rearrange the
coefficients to make them more
compressible so if you put numbers that
are similar or closer together
jpg has this DC predicted Huffman code
so it's better compression if the
similar numbers are together so this is
one thing you can do jpg rescan that's
really good but not so good compression
efficiency you can also change the
Huffman code for an arithmetic code so
arithmetic codes were known in the 80s
but they were patented so nobody uses
them but we can use them now so you
could imagine reading coding them as
there's a tool that does that so that
has not as good decompression speed but
you know the compression efficiency is
better and anytime you have an
arithmetic code you know really what
matters is how good can you predict
whether the next bit is a 1 or a zero
because the way it works if I know for
certainty that the next bit is a 1 and
it is a 1 it consumes zero bits in the
output and if I know for certainty it's
a 1 and it turns out to be a zero like a
Trump election or something like that
that no one expected then it's like
infinite bits in the output that's sort
of the the Faustian bargain you make
with these arithmetic codes the better
that you can predict this is sort of a
machine learning problem the better you
can predict the probability of the next
bit being a zero one the better savings
you can get when you're right and then
if you want to be crazy about it like
this German guy you can do the world's
most complicated arithmetic code you can
take all the coefficients of the file
this global operation resource them in
the most compressible order and then
have a huge model like a hundred
thousand parameters in your machine
learned model to predict whether the
next bit is gonna be a one or a zero and
then use an arithmetic code based on
that probability model to compress them
so this gets about 23% compression
efficiency very slow to decode because
it takes all these sort of global
operations the challenge here is that in
the file system context you cannot have
a global operation on a file because no
part of the system of this distributed
file system ever sees a file at once
instead these files are divided up into
small blocks
content addressed blocks and they're
stored redundantly so if you upload a
JPEG file to any of these services
Dropbox and Google they're all sort of
similar well I don't know that I'm
guessing Ivan I can tell you about
Dropbox but the files are split up into
separate pieces and each piece is
content address so it's addressed by the
hash of its contents which means that
they don't have to store duplicates you
have two people both upload a trunk
that's all zeros you know they only have
to store that once so when your computer
wants to retrieve a file from Dropbox it
goes out to separate back in file
servers and it asks for different chunks
different blocks of the file so you can
imagine it would be nice to be able to
compress them and turn each chunk into a
correspondingly compressed chunk we call
this lepton a lepton file representing a
certain number of bytes of the original
file but then when the client downloads
it it ends up getting the original jpg
piece of the original file this is the
way it would have to work because
anything else either if somebody has to
know the whole JPEG file at once that's
not gonna work and also if you want to
send the lepton file down to the client
that's not going to work because there's
no way to sort of upgrade every client
in the world and they have like a
million clients and so it has to be sort
of this transparent compression
operating at the file system trunk level
on each back-end file server because
that's where they have the redundancy so
the challenge of this is that you have
to be able to take the file and store
and decode it in these independent
chunks and these chunks can start at any
byte offset because they're sort of up
to the file system people they're not up
to me I mean the files have already been
sort of pre chunked and you know you
have to be able to achieve like good
decoding speeds so people have like
hundred megabit per second connection to
the Internet you can't suddenly make the
whole Dropbox ten times slower they
won't like that even if they never don't
load the files when they do download
they're gonna notice and it's very
important not to lose data so you have
to make sure that this whole system is
immune to any sort of pathological
adversarial input every time the program
changes it was very important that it
runs successfully and identically on a
billion files each compiled with three
different compilers and it has to be
completely deterministic because the
thing that terrifies an organization
like this is that they'll compress a
file someone will upload a file
they'll compress it they'll double check
at that time and decompress and make
sure they get the same thing they'll
store it and then six months later the
same user will try and download the file
they'll decompress it and the hash will
not match anymore and then they're in
trouble so it's that non-determinism
that they're very terrified by if
there's just a bug
when they go to compress it and then
they decompress again if they don't get
the same answer then they can write me a
nasty email and say you know we were
never gonna work with Stanford again
we're very unhappy with you but if they
store the file because it worked once
and then it never works again then
they've lost someone's data so that it
has to be deterministic which is not
something that our programming languages
really are very good at ensuring it's
very hard to avoid non-deterministic non
determinism in a normal sort of
programming language all right so the
question is how does the file server
when the client goes to the backend file
servers and requests pieces of a jpeg
file the file server has to decode it
from our crazy format which is fine but
then the hard part is it has to
re-encode it in this JPEG format and how
does a file server star tree encoding
for midstream that's sort of the
challenge the same challenge as before
and has to be able to reincarnate stream
however it turns out to be much much
easier than before because JPEG is
really simple so people it's so easy to
be sort of scared of it oh it's this
1980s thing it's a Huffman code it's
very complicated it turns out if you
just sort of play with it it's not that
complicated
so we formulated this JPEG encoder this
DC predictive Huffman code err in
explicit state passing style and then we
implemented it as a pure function in
those side effects so there's a state
object that evolves byte by byte as it's
writing out the JPEG file and then once
you have that state object you can
resume from anywhere even in the middle
of a Huffman code word so Huffman code
would be 17 bits you want to be able to
resume anywhere because the byte
boundary might not be lined up with it
so it turns out you can get that state
down to 16 bytes it's not that
complicated it's the partial Huffman
code word it's the one you're in the
middle of sending you know you say well
I've sent three bits of my seven bit
code word so you've got four bits left
over that's one thing you have to save
and then it's DC predicted so you have
to save the prior DC values it turns out
to be not that complicated and you know
you can just once it's functional you
can have a regression test and say well
give me the hardest file you have and
I'll just try freezing the state at
every byte boundary and then resuming
from there and I'll see if I get
identical results and you know we got
that down to 16 bytes so once you have
this sort of ability to back up and
experiment with different choices it
turns out to be a lot of fun to make so
we ended up doing this and we use the
this ability to break the file up and
start encoding from midstream we use it
for two purpose
one is to comply with these file system
block boundaries the second is just to
have parallelism even within a single
file server we may as well just split it
up into eight pieces so that we can
decode it more quickly so I'll show you
the benefit of just the second choice
just decoding a single block here again
is the three terms of techniques and
here's the software that we published so
this is sort of open source software it
ends up being almost the same
compression efficiency is the crazy
German guy not quite but almost but it's
nine times faster and that's within a
single block so if you have two blocks
it's you know it's 18 times faster so oh
I this is the fun well just so it's
encoded 150 billion files it's 200
petabytes have been encoded saved like
46 petabytes and consider they have a
cluster running this program this one
program consumes 300 kilowatts
continuously compressing the back
catalogue and actually they suspected a
bug at one point and they turned it off
and the power consumption only dropped
to like buy half so the program is
there's a cluster running that only runs
the program that consumes 300 kilowatts
but half of that is just like the blinky
lights on the front of the machine you
consume half the power whether you're
running the program or not so four
people actually make computers this
seems stupid but anyway it incentivizes
them to keep my program running all the
time so the lesson here is that a little
bit of functional programming can go a
very long way we're talking about 16
bytes of state here this is not that
hard to keep track of but by having it
you can do all kinds of crazy things
like 23% compression of hundreds of
petabytes of JPEG files fitting within
an existing context where you don't
control the boundaries all right okay so
great so that's how a company and a
different company made you know money ok
so let's talk about some of the work we
did where there's a get another benefit
of functional programming or you know
it's functional style of implementation
where we were able to make a video
conferencing program well it works
better than ones like Skype or FaceTime
or hangouts or WebRTC and the advantage
here is that by having a functional
abstraction to the video codec we can
explore the consequences of an execution
path we can follow an execution path a
little bit and if we don't like it we
can abandon it so we don't have to
commit to an execution batch just to try
it out we get that again by this sort of
purely functional abstraction so this is
going to appear in this year's an STI
and then the observation here is that
you know if you try videoconferencing
Skype or FaceTime or hangouts or Chrome
web RTC OH
for any sort of network where there's
uncertainty or variability I don't
people do this anyone ever video
conference like when you're the car or
anything like that no one tries it if
you try to do how will it work yeah yeah
anyone else had this experience people
just don't even try I got on this topic
actually when I was in grad school and
my adviser says I don't think there's a
good topic you know it's a very well
studied topic Skype and FaceTime and
hangouts and they says I have to go home
and see my kids today so we're gonna
have to continue this conversation over
videoconference so he's skyping home
through the streets of Boston with his
phone up like this and it was terrible I
couldn't no one could understand and
then is like okay maybe you you know it
is a good topic to work on so one of the
problems here in our opinion is that the
way these programs are architected is
that companies are scared to sort of do
it all in-house so video codecs are
thought to be a specialized thing you
have to buy a chip to do it and
companies outsource that so when we once
when I was in you know in grad school we
developed a transport protocol which is
a way of sending data over the Internet
and a way of estimating the available
capacity of the network and we thought
our transfer protocol was pretty cool
and we went to Skype and we said you
know you should use it it'll be better
than Skype they said well it doesn't
really work that way because we don't
make the whole system our video codec
don't tell anybody but we licensed it
from Google because at that time Skype
was using vp8 they say we don't have the
flexibility to combine these things in
the way you're talking about we have
sort of separate modules we have a
transfer forego that we make and we have
a video code at that Google banks and
they interface sort of at arm's length
it's a modular system and it's in art in
my opinion it's too modular or the
boundaries between the modules are just
not good yes sir well we don't have data
on that
Braddock's only about two years old
what was that no I don't I don't I don't
know so so this is sort of the current
architecture that these two compiled
then I bet when we went to Google and we
said okay you should use this transfer
protocol because you make the video
could I can they say well yes but as it
turns out this is unhanged so we don't
make the whole transfer protocol we
license that from an ax company called
video and then later I was on a panel
discussion with the chief scientist of
video and I complained and she said oh
no no no Google we didn't give them our
good stuff we just gave them our
consumer stuff you have to be testing
our
it's very hard to pin these companies
down but ultimately I believe the
problem is that the architecture is too
arm's length so what happens is that the
Transfer Protocol can tell the encoder
what sort of bitrate to target there's
an estimate that the network has a
certain bitrate and these systems
started sort of in the world of ATM you
know where you could reserve and
isochronous deliveries channel over the
network and get a particular bit rate
and this tell the encoder oK we've
reserved one megabit per second encode
at that and then the encoder based on
that chooses its encoding parameters so
chooses a frame rate it chooses a
quantizer you know some quality setting
and then the transport protocol is stuck
sending whatever the encoder created
even if it overshoots or undershoots
that capacity the problem is that the
capacity on the internet can change you
know it's not like ATM you don't have
provision capacity can change and
there's sort of too much latency between
the the encoder and the the transfer
protocol to match the encoders the data
that the encoder is generating to the
varying capacity of the network so what
actually happens in WebRTC for example
if the encoder generates a frame that's
too big they don't have a way to not
send it so the encoder the network
thinks that the network the Transfer
Protocol thinks the network can
accommodate a frame of a certain size
the encoder for whatever reason
generates a frame that's too big which
can happen all the time these encoders
on a single frame basis it's very hard
to target a particular compress frame
size a priori because you don't know
what the correlation is gonna be between
a frame and the previous frame until you
sort of try to compress it so it's on a
single frame base is very easy to
overshoot or undershoot and that's why
these encoders specify an average bit
rate they they don't tell you a
particular frames gonna be a particular
size nonetheless for the most part the
transfer protocol just has to send it
even if it knows at that time that the
frame is too big it still has to send it
and then it screws up the network it
causes congestion and then they enter
what they call you know they say well
now I know that I've screwed up the
network so I'm gonna pause the input to
the encoder I'm not going to encode any
more frames for a while I'm gonna wait
for this congestion to clear but it
would have been much better just to
pause the output from the encoder for
the transfer protocol to tell encoder
you know what you made a frame that's
too big I'm not gonna send it I'm gonna
throw that away I'm not gonna send that
and screw up the network try again
encode another frame that'll be smaller
send that one that would be nice but
once the encoder has encoded a frame you
know it's it's gone through a state
transition remember
that's the interface encode a stream the
encoder has the state inside itself
there's no way to tell it to sort of
back up so that's that's what we wanted
to explore if you can explore an
execution path without committing to it
you know what sort of benefits can you
realise so if you build like a combined
algorithm with one control loop so
there's not there's not sort of a
framerate and a bitrate these are not
separate there's one rate and every time
through the control loop we call the
transfer protocol function we call the
video codec function we say what should
what the capacity of the network what
size should the frame be we go with just
one control loop can we build an
application where the video
transmissions better match the varying
capacity of the network so in the system
we have a video aware congestion control
scheme a video aware transport protocol
scheme and we have a sort of network
aware video codec and they're they're
fused together to sort of better match
the Volvic capacity so what we do this
is we it's the same video codec that I
showed you in the first part of the talk
it's there's that decode given state in
code given state that's the interface we
don't use the rebase and every time we
go through this control loop there's an
estimate from the network for the
transfer protocol about what is the size
that the frame should be how big do we
think the the network can accommodate
right now because if you send more than
that you can cause packet loss or you
can cause a cue to accumulate you don't
want either of those to happen so
there's some estimate about the size and
every iteration of the control loop it
would be very nice if we could tell the
codec you know we think the next frame
should be 17 kilobytes so make it
exactly 17 kilobytes there's no way that
codecs can't do that because to do that
you have to sort of try to compress it
and see how big it ends up being so
instead we just we beat this with trying
multiple options so we tell the encoder
you know what try a higher quality
version than the one you just sent and
try a lower quality version of the same
frame so we have one state that we
assume the decoder is at we ask the
encoder to try a higher quality encoding
and lower quality encoding both based on
the same state and then the transfer
protocol has options because it can look
at what the actual size is that it wants
the frame to be and it can look at what
the sizes turn out to be that it's
actually gotten from the encoder you
know there's a frame that's 20 kilobytes
is a frame that 10 kilobytes so it has
three options it can send the twenty
kilobyte version it can send a ten
kilobyte version or if it doesn't think
the networks ready it can just say you
know what we're not going to do it we're
gonna take them all again we're not
gonna send a frame at all and we'll just
go through the control loop another time
we'll encode a new frame whatever next
comes off the can
but we're gonna base it on still the
same state of the decoder it says if
nothing ever happens just a total
do-over so this turns out to be a very
powerful capability to have to explore
execution states to the encoder without
committing to any of them because it
means the framerate of the system is
totally dynamic it's not 60 frames per
second it's not 10 frames per second we
send a frame or don't send a frame at
any moment based on whether we think the
network can accommodate it
so then erect gets good we can send more
frames and then it works bad we just
skip more frames but ultimately there's
no time evolution like a frame rate
that's evolving and forces the computer
to send a frame when it doesn't want to
you never send the frame unless the
network is ready alright so how do we
evaluate this we were very proud of the
evaluation testbed which the people in
this room built this is the first time
this appears to have ever been done is
that we have a comparative evaluation of
different blackbox video compression
system video conferencing systems in a
sort of codec agnostic way so the goal
here was to have a totally reproducible
video that we that we stream that we you
know reproducible web video conference a
reproducible network conditions that we
test over and we want to run the
unmodified versions of the system under
test so I don't want to be changing
Skype or FaceTime or hangouts or WebRTC
I'm gonna run them unmodified and of
course our system and we'll just see how
well they do and the target metrics are
this sort of standard quality of
experience metrics the delay what is the
delay between when something happens at
the sender and the first time you see
that the receiver and the quality which
is the same structural similarity metric
so here's the actual system so we have a
computer with a very cool and expensive
Blackmagic HDMI input output card so we
have a synthetic and that synthetic we
have a real video conference that some
of our colleagues generously provided so
these are them pretending to have a
Viacom what did you tell them to do you
say pretend I have a video conference ok
so that's a pretend real video
conference actual people and then it's
60 frames per second High Definition and
then we put on each frame we put a
barcode identifying exactly which frame
it is and this is a big barcode every
dot there is 16 pixels across and the
goal here is that the barcode will
survive any sort of lost video
compression and video transmission so we
barcode every frame 60 frames per second
and we play it outside this computer at
this very rigorously timestamp way so
this this card has a hardware timestamp
so it can tell us exactly sub
millisecond granularity when did that
frame leave the HDMI port and then it
goes into this box which is made by a
company in downtown Palo Alto that
converts HDMI into a pretend webcam so
HDMI comes in here and what comes out is
a USB port that pretends to be a webcam
and you can plug that USB port into a
Mac running FaceTime or a PC running
Skype or a Linux machine running
hangouts or our system and they all
appear to be a webcam so these computers
think they're getting webcam input but
they're really getting our are
reproducible test video with barcodes on
it and it's all you know time stamp to
the millisecond so then that computer
sends video running Skype or whatever
it's running however it wants over a
time varying network whose a trace of
sort of variations in capacity is
synchronized to the video and then it
goes to a receiver computer also running
the unmodified skype or facetime or
hangouts we fullscreen the window on the
receiver computer and it comes out the
HDMI port on that computer back into the
same fancy card that the video came out
of where it gets time-stamped on receipt
by the hardware clock and that same PCE
car on the same time base that the video
was sent at and then we just recognize
the barcode which is really big so we
can do so we match up the corresponding
frames when we sent that frame when we
received the same frame then we can get
the frame by frame delay of every single
frame and once we have the corresponding
frames we can measure the quality the
structure similarity between what we
sent and what we received so that's the
benchmark so let's look at some Network
measurements and then we'll look at some
video measurements so here's a network
measurement we just looked at what
happens when the network gets worse for
a while and then it gets better for a
while so this shaded region is the
network's capacity so it just gets worse
and then it gets better and we can see
how the different transport algorithms
behind these schemes follow or don't
follow then our X bearing capacity so
salsa fee is the red line that's our
scheme so you can see it sort of follows
the networks capacity when it gets bad
we're sending really bad video or maybe
no video at all and once it's good we
sort of resume and you can look at Skype
and web part you see they're a little
more stubborn so Skype tries to send it
a particular rate and it continues
trying to send at that rate even when
the network has fallen out beneath it
and there used to be a mentality well
there still is a mentality but you want
to have slowly varying video quality
it's not good to change the user's video
quality too rapidly and it makes sense
that maybe you don't want to increase
the quality too rapidly because you know
it could fall away again but it does not
work to try and slowly decrease the
quality if the network has already
fallen out beneath you because all
you're doing by sending faster than that
we can accommodate is is causing packet
loss or building up a queue it
ultimately does not serve the Clawd of
the user there's no reason to slow down
the decrease because you can look at
what happens in Skype actually recovers
here whatever our GCS is totally
confused and it's it's in it's like bad
network mode it's just not sending
anything at all so we can also look at a
video metric of delay here every dot
here is a frame of video and we can see
the delay between when it's sent when
it's received so WebRTC is sending
basically oh sorry it's also fee is
sending basically constant delay and
then when the network is bad the delay
spikes up for bit and then it recovers
pretty quickly that's the red line Skype
it doesn't slow down fast now if it
builds up a big delay and it takes a
while to recover and WebRTC has starts
out with a big delay it spikes and then
it gets totally confused and sends a
bunch of frames here then there's
nothing for about eight seconds it sends
one frame here and then nothing for a
while because it's in this bad network
mode this is Skype in chrome 62 okay
it's a recent it's a recent Chrome so we
can also look at the quality metrics and
we see them here so here we see the
video delay is on the x-axis and the
best delay is again on the right side we
flip the x-axis and the quality
structural similarity is here on the
y-axis so the best schemes will be up
into the right so here's salsa fee which
gets the best video quality and the best
delay of any of the sort of conventional
schemes over a Verizon LTE type network
trace so I'm not sure that I mean it it
surprised me that we're able to get
better quality so maybe these schemes
using very fancy video compression
formats but vp9 SVC or h.264 a video
encoder written by one graduate student
in three months for an outdated format
is able to beat all of these schemes on
a video compression metric of structural
similarity that suggests that
improvement in video codecs are not that
helpful in this context the difference
between vp8 and vp9 SVC or one grad
student versus Google it didn't cause
Google to win this one but improvements
in video systems must have considerable
low-hanging
route if one research group building a
better system with a better architecture
can outperform the best video codecs so
this is over Verizon trace here's an 18
t trace again best quality and they're
comparable delay to Skype
here's over a t-mobile trace again best
quality lowest delay so I think this
this mode where we think of a video
codec is a specialized thing that
operates on streams and we don't ask for
the ability to introspect on its state
or not even to inspect the state but
just to be able to save and restore the
state this is not a world you want to be
in every component in your system you
want to be able to save and restore the
state and talk about the state because
to treat these components to something
foreign that you just have to live with
oh the codec produced too big a frame
when we have to send it anyway I mean
it's just it's you don't get good
results you have to be able to reason
about state and integrate these control
loops in order to get good quality
results I think that's the lesson there
that's a third benefit of the sort of
functional programming paradigm alright
I'll take questions there and then we
can move on to the fun demo yes well I I
mean this graph is using structure
similarity as the video quality metric
well I think it's possible I mean we had
this work as funded by Google I should
say so I think if they had we go over
there and we presented this work at
Google I think if they had a you know a
better metric for us they would tell us
I mean what do you what did they say
when we they seem to believe SM is a
reasonable metric you know they do care
about compatibility with hardware codecs
I mean that you know that to implement
this you need the interface to the codec
to be able to save and restore the state
so hangouts is supposed to work on sort
of every cell phone in the world I think
that is one limit tape there's a major
limitation of the scheme is that it
you need the interface from the codec so
I'll just quickly talk about the last
thing we're do which is trying to
outsource sort of any do I have it here
so if it observes any calculation to the
cloud so take just a universal
abstraction to take anything you might
do on your computer
on your laptop and extend it to the
cloud so they sort of laptop extension
workloads and we talk abouts a little
bit but you know what are the things you
spend CPU time on your computer it's
like compilation maybe searching for
things maybe analysis j-john analyze 20
terabytes of Antarctic and Arctic radar
images that would how long can that take
yeah take a long time so anything
interesting that you want to do with a
computer that could take a long time
what if there were sort of common
interchange format an intermediate
representation for the cloud kind of
like the LLVM ir or like halide some way
of declaratively specifying a lambda
expression for the calculation that you
want to do and then let's talk about
evaluating it maybe locally but maybe
also across 10,000 lambdas or 10,000
open whisks or maybe if everything's
purely functional reproducible maybe we
just sort of throw it up on Reddit and
let anyone evaluate the functions you
know any way anyone could volunteer that
was maybe too much for this group anyway
anyone could evaluate the functions and
give us the answer as long as it's
deterministic it doesn't really matter
who's doing it it doesn't have to be
Amazon it could be anybody so that's the
idea so we've done this sort of four
compilation and four video compression
so I want to see if we can get the demo
to work so we have this system here so
here I have ffmpeg which is a video
compression tool it takes about 10
minutes to compile so I think if I just
did make dash j8 let's see here
all right so here's here's what it
normally looks like just take so long
I'm not gonna make you sit here for 10
well it's 10 minutes on a single core so
it'd take like well this is a 4 core
machine anyway I'm not gonna make you
sit for there but that's this what
compiling looks like what if instead we
try and take this make file and infer a
lambda expression infer a very big
expression of nested functions that have
to be evaluated to ultimately produce a
program called ffmpeg so that's
basically what we've built and the thing
that we didn't want to do is have to
learn anything about make files because
that's super unpleasant you can imagine
we're gonna read the make file and we're
gonna infer the functional dependencies
between stages and that's not so much
fun because you know no other leaving
likes make files I mean there's people
who do ninja and people who basil and
people do see make you don't want to
sort of tie to a particular make file or
something like that so the question is
can we infer or reverse-engineer the
functional dependency
one of these eunuch C tasks just by sort
of pretending to actually do it so
that's what we built I'll make sure you
should we do the hello world let's try
the hello world okay so here I have a we
have a hello world program just see the
last time I gave this talk hi III okay
so here we've got hello world and I
could compile it to hello like that what
if we fake do it what if we pretend to
do it so we have a program here called
GG so our system is called GG it's the
Stanford builder George Goodman is the
freemason who built Stanford University
you can see his name in the in the main
quad so we have the the Stanford builder
we're gonna infer the functional
dependencies of a compilation process so
I'm just gonna prepend this GG and fir
here to the command line and it it
pretends to compile but it doesn't
really compile it runs it through
something we call model substitution so
we run not the real GC we were GCC
excuse me we're on a model of GCC and
this model has to figure out for every
stage and the real compilation so what
we just did here was we pre processed it
we compiled it we assembled it and we
linked it to produce this file called
hello for every step we need to be able
to model the functional dependencies of
that step so what does it take to
pre-process a file what do you have to
know you need to know what's in the file
you need to know what's in all the
header files that the file includes and
that's most of it you also need to know
like what is the preprocessor itself you
know so if you had that information
what's in hello dot see what is in the
preprocessor itself you know which
version are using and then what's in all
the header files that it's going to
include or at least what which header
files does it want to include that would
be enough there's the functional
dependencies and then you could run that
anywhere what does it take to compile a
file you basically just need to compile
the pre-processed input and the compiler
and you run the compiler in the pre
process input and that produces the
assembly output and then to assemble a
file you need the assembly output and
the assembler you run the assembler on
the compiled output the assembled output
compiled output and that produces the
object file
so what is this term when we take a
program and we apply it to data that's
sort of like a valent apply right it's
like the list community coming back that
we heard about earlier you can't you
can't keep us down except this is all
just C++ it's not smart people were
involved in this so so that's so what we
can see is the output here it did write
a file called hello but if we look at it
it's not a real thing
it's a funk it is a memorialization of
what would have to happen if we ever
wanted to actually evaluate the output
of that step of functions so we have a
hash here and we can describe it and
what it tells us is that okay there's
some function that's gonna be applied
the executable is called GCC and here's
the exact hash of that executable so
it's totally content addressed and then
here are the data dependencies here are
the arguments to the function one is the
contents of GCC here's some helper
program that GCC depends on here's the
linker here is an anonymous dependency
that is another thunk so what is
happening here this is the last step
we're linking it so the inputs to the
linker are the object file and then the
linker itself and the linker runs on the
object file so the object file is not
known at this stage because that's also
a function of pension this is like F of
G of H etc so this is the output of an
intermediate stage in the compilation
and we can look at this thunk - Gigi
describe this guy so this is the
assembly step so we have the assembler
in here and the input is the compiled
output and the the output in assembling
the output is the object file etc so we
have this chain of dependencies so
that's for hello world but we can run
any sort of build process and as long as
everything hard that it tries to do has
a model we can extract a functional tree
a lambda expression from what was a very
messy and complicated thing so let's try
with ffmpeg I'll make clean here I hope
this works
so we'll dig in Gigi infer make so this
is gonna run a whole bunch of GCC's I
shoot it out with the time let's do it
we'll do it the time try to impress you
okay
time so this is gonna run a whole
of compiles and links and preprocessors
and all kinds of crazy things but it
doesn't really run them it just runs the
models and that took 3.8 seconds and at
the end we have something called ffmpeg
but but if it's just a thunk and I if I
wanted to force the thunk I could run
the shell script and it would compile in
lambda in the cloud and then produce an
executable and then download executable
and then run it so let's let's do that
and I'm gonna do it explicitly so we can
see the UI what we'll see if it works we
don't have the best failure handling
right now but it's purely functional so
if it crashes we just control C and do
it again it picks up from where I left
off
so it's a bonus okay well how about how
power is to be two hundred or two
hundred okay here we go all right ready
okay done 300k there we go okay so we
see here there's two hundred pending
lambdas here's the number that are done
there's five thousand separate functions
to compute and we've spent six cents
seven cents eight cents we're 90% done
all right now we get down to the final
linking stage this is kind of on dolls
law coming to bite us last one come on
oh I wish this had worked in my last
more important venue for giving this
talk anyway it worked and we can run it
and hey it's ffmpeg just built in the
cloud so that was a deterministic
evaluation of a lambda expression that
had 5,180 sub expressions totally
functional and that lambda expression
was learned by running the make file
through this model substitution where
every stage we didn't run the real stage
we ran it a fake version that sort of
inferred what to do so we believe at
least I hope that this kind of
abstraction can allow people to
outsource anything you might do on your
laptop if you can divide into lots of
tiny pieces and write it out in this
sort of JSON format which is not that
hard outsource it to lambda or Open
whisk or a family of ec2 machines or
maybe even crazy people on reddit
because once it's all deterministic you
can run the calculation anywhere it's
deterministic and Condon dressed and you
can even share the memoization cache so
when I've evaluated this function to be
something else facts
try that make clean Gigi Gigi in fur
make - J okay and now let's GG forced SJ
200 SS f f/a okay ready see it was
memorized so all those 5,180
sub-expressions have a have a name they
have a hash and we've memorized that
that that thunk when forced evaluates to
a certain output so we can resolve the
whole thing from the cache so no two
people ever have to evaluate the same
function twice so this is kind of the
world I want to live in where you don't
depend on Amazon or IBM or anyone to be
honest you express you things in
functional format and then you can have
sourcing to anyone you want and it's
totally interactive and fast and you can
run 5,000 jobs in like 10 seconds so
ultimately I believe that sort of
granular functional interfaces of
computing resources this is the way we
got to go anything that works on streams
or anything that's big and scary we got
to blow that up weak the point of being
a hacker is to not be scared anymore and
if you divide things into small enough
pieces no one is scary it is worth
refactoring these interfaces to the
codec or the compiler or TCP and machine
learning
whatever we're most sort of scared of is
most grody some neural network blow it
up functions and the ability to sort of
save and restore program State it turns
out to be a very powerful tool even if
you can't understand what's in the state
just being able to do that very powerful
I showed you that for video encoding
where the benefit of the functional
style was paralyzing in tiny little
pieces I showed it for lepton where the
benefit is being able to match the
arbitrary boundaries of a distributed
file system I showed it to you for salsa
fee where it's being able to explore an
execution path without committing to it
so we can match the video codecs
generated bit stream to the network's
bearing capacity and I showed it for
hopefully everything sort of compilation
of everything in the cloud for pennies
thank you very much
[Applause]
you